[Music]
let
uh good evening everybody and welcome to
meeting of traffic council's planning
and development management committee my
name is councelor Stanley and I'm the
chair of this committee before we start
Mee proper ask if anybody present intend
to photograph film or the
meeting thank you in any event we all
been recorded for line and subse
broadcast on the council's YouTube
channel continuing on to my mediate
right is councelor Lawrence Walsh who
shair this committee to our left and
right Council officers in planning legal
and highways d sides of the table all
members of the committee who are all
local counselors I there as they
speak to the agenda I attendances to
note our attendance I just have to note
any apologies we have apologies to see
from councelor sh Pro we have councel K
acting as a thank you
councel item two Declarations of
Interest MERS to give notice of any
personal or prejudicial interest and the
nature of that interest related to any
it on the agenda in accordance with the
accepted code of conduct does any member
wish to declare an
interest thank you members I have one
item
11845 all present I'll be accusing
myself from this item as I have to work
on this prior to the meeting item three
minutes to receive and so determined to
approve as a correct record the minutes
of the meeting held on M of November
2023 can have a proposer please thank
you
second thank you thank you councilors
item four questions members of public we
have no questions members of the public
this evening item five is information
report where we consider a report the
head of Planning and Development to be
tabled at the meeting this report has
been so
taed item six application to cor
provision to develop to consider the
attached report of the head of Planning
Development for the following
applications and we have for tonight the
process is the same in each case the
items introduced M planning T if we have
speakers on the item they then speak
next M of the public get three minutes W
members get five minutes I will then
open up the item for debate M of the
committee only and then we'll come to a
decision by a majority vote the first
item on the agenda is
11907 rear to shy Avenue in tin on item
63 of the pack and M
in thank you chair um the application
site relates to a garage located the
rear of two shy Avenue in timley which
is a takeaway with a flat above forming
the end unit in a commercial Terrace
neighboring properties to the rear are
residential to the west side is the
vacant her and Hounds public house there
is a rear Alleyway access of Seymour
Grove to the east Planning Commission is
sought for conversion of this garage to
an educational building in terms of
layout this would contain two tutorial
classrooms a reception area and a WC
proposed hours after school until 7:00
p.m. Monday to Friday and 8:00 a.m. to
400 p.m. on Saturday the building will
be closed on Sundays and bank holidays
there will be two employees on site and
a maximum of six students at any one
time the existing flat roof would be
replaced by hip roof with front
elevation alterations including a new
window and door openings the existing
side windows would be bricked up access
would be from a single front door facing
onto the rear rear alley which is
accessed by a single GR proposal
includes external bin storage and
bicycle parking the key issues for
consideration are the use of the site
design impact on residential immunity
and highways and parking officers
considered the proposal would have
educational and economic benefits for
the local area whilst the external
appearance of the building is considered
satisfactory the use of the building is
not considered to verely affect the
immediatey of neighboring residential
dwellings the lack of on-site car
parking is not considered precluded
proposal given the small scale Nation
the scheme character of the local area
and bicycle storage condition it is
considered that the proposal is in
accordance with the core strategy and
policies in the mppf and as such
recommend applications recommended for
approval subject to conditions chair
thank you Mr Mr H and Council B next
which have you decided which one
first Mr if you get the mic thank
you
got minut to
speak excuse me I'm hard of hearing so
if I speak loud it's because I'm hard of
hearing not
aggressive we understand we sorry so yes
say if you as you begin press on the
microphone and then we'll be able to
hear you turn mic phone on
yes
good evening
everybody your
[Music]
microphone I'm here on behalf of the
residents on and around SEO Road like to
reiterate the reason why we rejected
this planic
application highways agency Amy and
counselors in 2018 had meeting at my
house with the aim to reduce the traffic
on SE more Grove with the risk of
pedestrians caused by the
traffic additional Services would only
add to this
problem the upper floors above the
shots are now flat access to them is is
only from the rear entrance of the gate
through Gates through the shops there is
a mass of bins at the rear
with the
alleyway access is severely
limited Goods delivery drivers servicing
the shops consistently block the
alleyway and at times of stru traffic
flow when Parts on SE more
Grove this would compound the
problem with the classes proposed on the
site school children from from
surrounding areas would be at risk from
in increased traffic and parking
environment
challenges there are health and safety
issues with increased traffic dark
Alleyways very dark
Alleyways motorbike one of the B guys
got motorbike down there you come down
there you from res
jway been stored next to the garage
there are plenty of empty buildings in
the area which are better suited to
become Learning Centers and they
Carriage down the dark alleyway behind a
pizza shop chip
shop traffic has got worse since the her
ands closed it
car Papa John's has opened up and
recently Morrison's has just opened up
traffic is just this has been going on
for
years that's the newsletter that sent by
Ray valker how to
everybody SEO Grove parking problems sh
you update parking
problems I asked for all the couns
receive photographs of the area don't
day I don't excuse me excuse me sorry am
I allowed to no you're right but what
can't speak can't lie is people down the
down the road arguing because they can't
get
through you've got CL Road one end one
Road school at the other end somebody's
going to get hurt in the near
future I've Liv on number two SE BR for
30 years I seen two vehicles go through
the wall at number six recently going
around the corner I saw a car get
completely wiped out on the side he
didn't stop i' about to put security
cameras up all the way around the
house and a year and a half ago we had a
rat infestation from the rear of the
shots Enon got involved with that
Mr your remarks now three minutes is now
sorry I can't I W your remark your three
minutes is now still sorry your time's
up now right thank you thank you Mr
thank
youself from the microphone council
could you
microphone thank you Mr
[Music]
h
the reason the reason we can't do it is
all the evidence which is brought before
the
committee has to be an advance so that
the officers can take a look at it and
give their opinion we won't have time to
do that tonight so but you as you know
you'll get five minutes from when you
press the press the but microphone thank
you thank you chair for allowing me to
speak um this app has generated
relatively large number of objections
from residents who live in close
proximity to this site they experienced
the da inconsiderate parking and
obstruction particularly from delivery
transport that service the shops at this
location the report has not acknowledged
the important point that the only access
to all the GS above the RO shops is by
way of the narrow Alleyway at the rear
explain waste bins are generally kept
within the alleyway which further
restricts access at most
par for report makes reference to the
par 93 of the
nppf quote plan positively positively
for the use of shared space open space
and other local services to enhance the
sustainability of communities and
residential environments well clearly
from the reaction of the local residence
it doesn't do that pan 10 makes
reference to the core strategy policy L7
quoting a range of points on design and
development one of which being I quot
would improve the character and quality
of an area enhance the streeting or
character of the area and from the
objections you would have read none of
which the local residents would consider
to be a likely outcome par only to the
report refers to S spd3 parking
standards it takes no count of the
report of the actual parking issues
residents face on a daily basis at this
location the report is accepting of the
level of impact on highway safety and
residual cumulative impact on the road
Network it makes the point that there
are no parking restrictions on these
roads in order to justify this
application
acceptability I'm sure committee members
will agree with me that there any number
of roads and awards you represent that
desperately need parking restrictions
but which can be difficult process to
implementation so the current parking
restrictions at a particular location
should not be used as a justification
for dismissing any traffic issues and
incidents known to Residents from
actually living there but not registered
by the highways Department par 23 of the
report makes the point no cycle story
solution has been provided for any
condition to be determined this would be
of vital importance any
circumstances par 24 mentions proposed
bin storage in what is already a cled
Alleyway the pizza takeway proposes to
take its beIN into the re yard for their
comms these things are not done because
Ser Vin services are hit and miss a
service as far as ction SC so they
prefer to leave them out again these are
only proposed intentions and not
enforceable the usual Ro bins in the
other is a testament to the current
situation par 34 refers to economic
benefits to the local area which anyone
living there would struggle to
comprehend what they could be just as
the lack of on-site parking is not
considered to be a problem the applicant
has submitted medical down to support
his application to commercialize the
existing gares for I don't believe that
Council should be taking into
consideration for this appliation
because any approval cannot be ascended
in circumstances change in conclusion
this proposal is not suitable for this
site location and would add to the
existing problems of accessing the site
and pressures on nearby parking I would
urge the committee to seriously consider
the objections of the local residents to
this application and for it to be
refused on the ground stated thank you
sh thank you
Council have a written statement from
the applicants which
um
Mr thank you
chair good evening members I am here
today to respectfully request that you
approve my planning application to
convert a double garage into the Chief
space I'm aware of concerns raised by
some neighbors particularly related to
parking issues and I welcome the
opportunity to address these concerns in
detail firstly I want to emphasize the
critical role our tutoring Services play
in addressing the shortage of educators
in key subjects such as maths chemistry
physics and biology as the UK faces a
scarcity of qualified teachers in these
subjects our Academy stries to this Gap
by providing valuable educational
support to local students in providing
some context to my application I wish to
highlight the personal Journey that led
me to this career change due to
occupational asthma I had to reassess my
professional path and for the past five
years I have successfully ran Ching
services in a residential area without a
single complaint from my neighbors
recognizing the financial constraints
that currently limit me from purchasing
a larger building I assure the committee
that I'm fully committed to maintaining
harmony with the local community my
daughters are growing and this move is
aimed at finding a more suitable and
affordable location for ouring business
however one of the main objections
pertains to parking issues I wish to
assure the committee that our tutoring
sessions will be managed to minimize any
impact on local parking parents being
local residents will be encouraged to
walk and cycle or if driving drop off
and pick up their children problem
eliminating the need for extended
parking and Road Clear instructions will
be provided to parents to ensure smooth
coordination and to alleviate any par
related concerns cont concerns raised
this Ching space is not comparable to
larger organizations there will be a
maximum of six students using the
building at any one time our impact on
the community has been positive as
reflected in our commendable Google
reviews the alleyway will only be used
for pedestrial Access and I guarantee
that no vehicles will enter proper
arrangement have been made way to
disposal to prevent any obstruction and
the alley will be kept clear at all
times our tutoring sessions are confined
to the evening hours from 5 7 p.m.
avoiding any conflicts with liy vehicles
serving nearby shops during the day I
acknowledge the concerns raised by
neighbors particularly related to
parking and as a responsible and
considerate member of the community I
will ensure that the parking
requirements are related to our clients
in conclusion I humbly request the
committee Grant permission for this
valuable educational resource Grant
granting permission will not only be
transformed to our Academy but will also
contribute positively to the educational
needs of the community thank you very
much for your time understanding and
consideration thank you
CH thank you Mr Pro before I bring in
the members conne comments first of Alla
officer ISS
traff issues than
you yeah um in relation to parking this
is a very small development under the
mppf we have to demonstrate that
there'll be a severe impact it's not
considered that an educational
establishment that works well operates I
should say two hours a week with
slightly longer times on a Saturday will
generate a significant number of vehicle
trips um it's a maximum of six students
at any one time um if they are dropped
off by their parents or guardians or
other person the chances are that like
many Nursery schools sports centers and
the like that they'll be dropped off and
then the people will leave the area
coming back later to pick them up um
it's a sustainable area they don't have
to drive or be driven to get
there the road itself is
private and um there are no restrictions
along Seamore Grove so there's no
automatic right um for local residents
to park there it's available for the
public um and as I say the expectation
would be that people will just get
dropped off assuming they come buy motor
vehicle and they don't walk cycle or use
public transport or taxi service so from
our point of view there is no severe
impact there's no reason to object and
any objection couldn't be susp stained
appeal thank you chair um just in
relation to the actually the the um the
rights of access over that that um
Alleyway are not a planning matter um
but it is if I show you the photograph
it is wide enough as you can see for um
for Access down there um yes there there
are bins out there yes there is there is
other clutter um but that doesn't make
it unsuitable uh you know planning
application shouldn't be seeking to fix
existing problems in the area we can
only look at the impacts of this
development um it's not considered that
this development would make that
situation uh materially worse or or in
fact really any different at all because
there is again I'll go back to the site
plan you can see the dedicated bin
storage and you can see the dedicated
cycle storage there both of which are
secured by by planning condition uh so
those issues are are dealt with uh in
terms of comings and goings um as as the
the traffic officer said uh this is
limited there be limited number of
vehicle trips there' also be limited
number of people coming and going over
relatively limited periods of time so
it's not considered that there' be any
um uny noising disturbance uh caus to
neighboring residents as a result of
this activity taking place um it it is
it's an educational use um again it's
conditioned to be and remain in that
educational use so um we don't consider
this cause any real problems in the
local area thank
you any M wishing to
speak
[Music]
CC thanks chair um I think Mr Hugh the
speaker spoke spoke really well and and
I really feel for the residents around
there in terms of the problems of
traffic and parking I know the area
quite well I know there's a p johnes
there and a Morrison and I know was a
Papa John probably cars are turning up
all hours to to park on the streets and
probably causing numerous problems but I
think I agree with the head of planning
m k um that maybe we're keeping some of
those existing problems on onto the
applicant and I think that's unfair it
is a small operation and operation hours
don't seem to be excessive to me um it's
it's closed on Sundays and bank holidays
for instance um the pro proposed opening
hours R 5:00 p.m. to 700 p.m. Monday to
Friday and and 8:00 a.m. to 400 p.m on a
Saturday so so hopefully those times and
people dropping off you know hopefully
quite quickly and then Moving On Again
won't cause too many problems um or
extra problems to the ones that
currently exist this um I think also
paragraph 31 speaks about the um in the
committee report speaks about the um
entrance access and it's it's a level so
there's an EAS of access for wheelchair
users um
Etc um and there probably will be on
Saturdays for instance plenty of car
parking on nearby streets um but I can
see that will get busy at times but um I
think this ation does bring economic
benefits to the area you know that
tutoring is needed especially with the
current gr school system that we have in
the sou the B and other places so I
think I propose that we
um vote in line with off's
recommendation on this application
thanks chair thank you
coun thank you
chair um
sorry
thank you
ch um although I agree that it's
commendable that we're having for the
tuition opportunities for people I just
can't help but think that the location
is inappropriate for this kind
of business i' say um just looking at
the photos and getting an understanding
of the location and hearing the comments
from Mr human Council but I can't help
but but feel like it's going to create a
lot of issues for local residents
there and I understand how painful
parking and and traffic issues can be
when you when you live in an
area
um I know I know that certain weights to
give and parking and and whatever you as
Rebecca said it's not really a
consideration but I think it's important
that that is at least considered by us
as a
committee uh the bin locations you can
see they're all over the place and we
all know that vins just get thrown
everywhere and and the bit of Vin comes
whenever they can you just leave them
out and they get take whenever they can
be so I've got concerns about the safety
of the area as well it doesn't seem to
be a turning Circle um in that lane it
just see to be directly in and out which
concerns me around traffic so you're
going to have cars going directly in and
then reversing out so I have concerns
around that um so generally I just feel
like it's not suitable location so I'll
be um proposing to refuse the
location thank you councel
counc
thank you chair um my concerns mainly
are actually around around is well well
there a small amount of traffic I
appreciate that's up to six people at a
time um and you can't blame the
applicant
for the existence of of other shops and
things and takeways nearby I think the
issue I've got is that the what
hopefully people will walk there
hopefully people will go byy a bike
the reality of um parents dropping kids
to things like tutoring Services is they
do quite we turn up my car um if you
have people driving down there and then
reversing out how they get out um with
the bins and things in in play I think
it's a safety concern for kids coming
out of two place and whether they you
know VIs IL of the driver I just feel
like it's too much of a risk for me and
that I think a safety concern I
appreciate not lots of kids like it's a
school or something I appreciate that
but I think the location and that with
the alleyway um is not it's not ideal I
think if it was if it was wi if there's
Pavements on either if there's Pavements
on either side I I'd probably go it's
okay but we don't have pment so it's
it's an unadopted Road it's a private
road and we don't don't have papers of
safety for pedestrians so I think I'll
be seconding the proposal
to issues with the do we know what
the yeah I agree with what e Minister
counselors e minister
um yeah I just think it would be great
if people did walk there or cycle but
and it's nowhere near the tram so it's
not you can get on the tram the bus down
shury Avenue every half an hour so
people will be driving there uh I mean
this is in my ward it's the area that I
deliver to so I know how busy it is when
it comes to parking especially when it
comes to to Papa John's and and the
alleyway itself is is really quite small
I think there's so many empty buildings
throughout traffic that people could
probably use and we can utilize because
said so many businesses are moving out
of various building so why build a new
one when they can go elsewhere when it
comes to tutoring in the local area yes
it's great because we do have the gr
schools as that was highlighted but this
will cause a lot of Destruction to
people's lives if I would next I would
want people driving here and there
between 8:00 a.m. and 400 pm. on a
Saturday when I'm trying to relax and
also on our families with G children so
I wouldn't want people going at 5 7 o'
when I'm trying to send children so
again I application because I
don't
thanks chair um I'm interested in what
Mr H councelor but said about
historically that's a in a dangerous
road for traffic and what I'm just ask
our traffic officer is it particularly
on our radar see more grow no it isn't
and um the latest fiveyear validated
traffic collision data shows that in
this area there was one slight injury
Collision at the junction which took
place in
2018 so in Road Safety terms there's no
identified Ro problem and if I go back
10 years there's still only one
collision at the junction which took
place in
2018 and of I mean the existing use of
course is garages so you know there
would still be Vehicles going along yeah
um I don't doubt Mr Hume and Council
but's uh Integrity on trying to keep
that area safe and uh Mr Hume showed us
the um the letter from our old friend
Council
Bala famous politician in these parts
but I don't think it's particularly bad
at seeing more Gro that's not a very
good way of putting it but
it's not on our traffic radar has been
particularly dangerous and I don't think
it's going to generate that much traffic
and I hear what councilors have said and
uh we are about safety on on this
planning committee we don't want to
endanger anybody but to refuse this on
those grounds and and I think that is
the grounds that people are asking for
to refuse on traffic it would have to
have an it's described in the report an
unacceptable impacts on highway safety
and I think we demonstrated by
questioning that that that isn't going
to happen there is not a lot of activity
this is not a shop this is not people
com and going in 10 and 15 minutes I
went down to see the site today actually
saw Mr hum I didn't get to talk to him
he was going out but there was a lot of
spaces to park there's no parking
restrictions on S more growth so I'm
comfortable with this application share
and I would propose that we Grant it
thank you
thank
you um Council Walsh has taken a lot
what I was going to say so um yeah I
there's not much to add the the in terms
of planning the recommendation from the
traffic officer is not detailing the
real problem arising from these six
students and I think that there's
nothing that I've heard that really
impacts on the whole of SEO growth 24
hours a day whatever the capacity of
that roow this is going to have a
minimum there may be issues on S gr I
don't doubt that but this isn't going to
act to
signic and I I
support
Council yeah I I support this proposal
as well and I think it's actually going
to enhance that
area um the development of that that
small building I think
enh okay thank thank you counselor um
yeah I I listen with great interest to
what council got Mr H said but I also
can't see based
on S based on the um based on the input
from more traffic officers I can't see
this being an issue sy so
it's being proposed we've got two
proposals on the table take the negative
one
first turn down this
application see the reason you wish send
this
down I my reasons were basically safety
as pedestrians there's no pavement and
that's that's if there was a pavement I
would probably have gone it it's okay
but I think the lack of a pavement to me
for the pedestrians are going to be
going to send CH place and we have we do
have bins in the alleyway they are there
um they obstruct you and therefore you
know I think that it it could you could
land up with an incident and it's
something I can't you know I can't vote
for okay so refusion on the grounds of
safy
okay okay so it's been proposed
that what when you say and access to it
what Harmon you identifying in terms of
the access the fact that it's not
appropriate for to be going up and down
that road not wi it's not got to turn in
circle you're going to have lots of
people coming in and out all the time
can go in and then reverse out and being
able to turn out and try but that would
be an increase as opposed to the
existing situation where that can happen
anyway so is it the it's the impact on
top of the impct yes of this of this
develop proposed in second that we
refuse supplications so all those in
favor of refus application please
indicate all those against ref
application we now take the uh the
opposite um position which we been
proposed second that we allow this the
recommendation all those in favor please
indicates and all those
against okay so that's being passed in
line with officer recommendation thank
you memb next item on the agenda is
um 105 land off GF Road and sale it's on
page 10 of and Mr C the introduction Mr
[Music]
C
thank you
chair so the application Side comprises
open grass fields and agricultural use
the site is located with a designated
green Bel and the Mery Valley area of
landscape protection the site area is
2.67 hectares and is located at the
Eastern edge of traffic
B so Golf Road is designated ralway and
recreational route which also provides
connections to transer Trail along the
mercy
um in this image here you can see the
application site ased red the top of
this image is the is the river Mery and
to the bottom left is the M60 Motorway
Metro Link line and settlement of
sale so this is an image of a site taken
from go
Road this is within the site facing
Southeast to the very rear of the
site this is within the site site facing
north towards the river mercy and uh
towards cell go
Club this is a view towards Golf Road
from within the
site and this is a site in the context
of Golf
Road so this application seats planning
permission for the construction of a
battery energy storage system with a
design capacity of 1990 megaw which
could operate for three hours at a time
delivering a total of 270 Mega of energy
these are systems that enable renewable
energy to be stored at times of high
Supply and then released when there are
sures in customer demand 156 battery
units would be laid across the site
ancillary structures proposed include
small buildings a
substation storage containers and a
control room Landscaping works are also
proposed so as you can see on the side
pink and green the battery and inverter
units
uh there are two parking spaces uh down
the far Southeast end of the
site and accessor and tracks throughout
the
site so this is the site in The Wider
context so you got informal development
along the bottom of the image there you
have the M60 Motorway on the fire image
here and the r mer the top image there
this area here is s golf
blood this is one small section of the
elevations this shows a Transformer a
number of battery and inverter
units these are the battery units in a
bit more
detail this is the proposed
Landscaping so the Landscaping
enhancements the rear the site adjacent
to the
boundary Landscaping is propos Road and
also at the rear the site as
well
so this is from the landscape visual
impact assessment and this illustrates
the extent of of the application site so
this is taken from bar Lane the bridge
of M60 the red line indicates the extent
of development so that gives a an idea
of how large size
is this is taken from trans Trail um J
to the river Mery again this is very
back from the site but again it shows
the extent of development the red line
IND top of of the
image so these are other battery energy
storage schemes within the area within
the M
Valley so the W far right has a has
received plan permission in construction
the other two two Yellow Boxes they
received consent but have not yet been
implemented and the application say in
in red there it's worth noting the um
there is very much an informal line
development in green which which follows
um which follows on here following the
boundary
of so this application reported to
committee this application reported to
committee more than six representations
have been received country officer
recommendation these representations
site the contribution scheme would make
towards achieving Net Zero addressing
climate change and that the site can be
decommissioned after 25 years these
representations received during a second
round of consultation and after
fundamental concerns were raised uh with
the applicant about the scheme the
representations were also received
predominantly from a wider
area there are considerations in favor
of the proposal of significant weight
The Proposal would significantly
contribute to the local Regional and
National effort to reduce Reliance on
fossil fuels reduce greenhouse gas
emissions and Tackle climate change
development incorporates in technology
to enable the wider and efficient
application of renewable energy it would
increase Reliance on clean energy and
help stabilize energy storage and
production The Proposal would however
constitute an appropriate development in
the green belt which is by definition
harm to Green Bel and should only be
approved in very special circumstances
as per the national planning policy
framework significant additional harm is
also demonstrated by openness of the
green
Bel encroachment into the countryside
would occur and the scheme would
cumulatively add to the eroding of the
gap between neighboring towns
specifically s and
shorten this development would heavily
urbanize as parel land the structures
themselves would have a jarring physical
presence on this landscape any
Landscaping development would result in
a loss of long reaching views from Golf
Road towards the river Mig as you have
seen from the images from go Road it's
very open and you can see quite far into
the green
um the impression of this Gap not only
contributes towards both the
recreational value and visual amenity of
this area but it also visually enforces
the separation between laboring
towns significant harm is also caused to
the landscape character the recreational
value and visual amenity of the Mery
Valley Landscape which as is is an area
of landscape protection there would also
be some temporally limited harm to
residential immunity through some
disturbance during the construction
phase
these harms to the green belt and the
Mery Valley Landscape are afforded very
substantial
weight as stated in the mpf very very
special circumstances will not exist
unless a harm to the green
belt and the additional harm to the
landscape amenity and the recreational
value of this area is clearly outweighed
by other
considerations just to just to clarify
in that point in terms of that balance
it to GRE about harm and any other harm
which would need to be outweigh
so the benefits of this scheme are
afforded significant weight however
these do not outweigh the sub the very
substantially rated harms associated
with this development therefore it is
considered very special circumstances do
not exist The Proposal therefore
fails it's therefore recommended for
refusal thank you
chair thank you Mr C
Mar I think you've got the drill by now
and get three minutes when you press the
uh on the microphone thank
you good evening I'm Catherine I'm head
of development seide energy the
applicate and to secure your support
today for a proposal which excuse me
which we feel has very special benefits
to supply the local area with reliable
angry as well as make great ecological
and Landscape improvements and of course
enhance the local grid and and make
efforts to address s climate emergency
these present very special circumstances
for being permitted to any the
application has several expressions of
support for local people and no
[Applause]
obje there is an overriding an urgent
need to connect battery storage into
areas where the gd network has the
capacity to take it to support the
transition to Net Zero electricity
Network failure to do so poses a very
real threat to the future of clean
secure predictable and affordable
electricity supplies our project
connecting into South Manchester is
immensely important in this context to
select this site Craig side analyze all
grid Supply points in the local network
and South Manchester was identified as
part of the National Grid assessment as
having strategic importance to
accelerate battery connections
recognizing their vital role to deliver
Renewables needed to reach
um renewable targets by
2013 this site is the best for a
duration battery with a footprint for
enough power to discharge energy for
longer when needed most and to be
relevant in the future as technology
switch from Poss FS to electrical power
we assess other sites in the area that
they were either unsuitable or not
available for
development Gold Course creates a
natural boundary between recreational
green Bel and the Su of developed land
that runs from the golf club
substation and
area between existing develop land and
other consented and developed
schemes the site is not currently in any
recreational agricultural use and the
topography Falls away from go Road and
high most of the site from public year
mature vegetation screens it on several
sides and after discussion with the
planning department we amended the
design to keep a view from Gulf Road
over to the Mery Valley extensive extra
planting will screen the site from Gulf
Road Mery Valley and recreational routes
and Landscaping will tie the boundaries
of the site into the existing planting
that runs along the rest of GF Road and
fairy Lane and the boundary of the golf
course these large planting areas will
improve the onsite biodiversity and
green links between existing planting
this proposal is well located hidden
essential
infrastructure the longstanding
environmental benefits of this site far
way temporary impacts it will tie in
with the surroundings and the
infrastructure already on the site and
after 25 years it will be completely
reinstated having set the course for
green affordable and secure energy for
the local area and nationally these
benefits present very special
circumstances it
favor uh Mr kroer would you just talk us
little bit again through the very
special
circumstan great way to be given to that
by
the yeah thank you shf so in terms of
very special
circumstances the npf is quite clear
that any
um the npf is quite clear that um
basically any V
green um
is
yeah so inappropriate development in the
green Bel which this is is by definition
harm harmful to a green Bel and should
not be approved except in very special
circumstances when considering any
planning application local planning
authorities should ensure that
substantial weights given to any harm to
be green Val very special circumstances
will not exist unless potential harms
for green Bel by reason of inappropri
and any of the harm resulting from The
Proposal is clearly outweighed by other
considerations so the construction of
any new buildings in the green belt are
is inappropriate be in the
Bel the construction of new buildings uh
is inappropriate in the green Bel unless
a number of exceptions applied this
proposal doesn't fall within those
exceptions therefore it is an
appropriate Bel in the green
Val in accordance with the npf that is
by definition that is by definition
harmful in addition that there is harm
to openness of a green belt there is
harm through encroachment development
into the green belt and it would
cumulatively erod the gap between
between neighboring settlements so it's
contrary to a number of purposes for
including land with the green
B there is also additional harm in terms
of a landscape harm which is set out in
the report this is a an area of
landscape protection and the development
would have a harmful impact on that
landscape character so all these harms
are then taken together which then weigh
against those benefits and we're not you
know acknowledg for our very significant
benefits here in terms of the benefits
in terms of renewable energy and
reducing Alliance in fossil fuels but
the harm to the green B and the harm to
the landscape we feel TR very
substantial weight and that would
outweigh those significant
benefits okay thank you thank you Mr I
to counselor um G some great clarity to
my thinking I'm Min to V in L
recommendation on this one we're going
allow in the green bell me to be
absolutely sure if there are very
special circumstances that outweigh all
the green bell considerations I don't
dispute the need battery storage I
really don't um and give went to that
fact that there several possibilities
the battery storage exist in that area
but if you know around there the the
facilities that already got permission
they are separated by um they are well
separated they don't destroy the the
general aspect of the of that area this
application is different it's much
bigger um it'll also sit next to one of
the already planned uh units and what it
will do is give almost uninterrupted
view of Industrial Development Across
that part of the the green belt and um
if you know that area it's part of the
mer Val report says it's part of the um
the largest green area in the in the
Manchester
cation we do need battery storage we
absolutely do but it doesn't need to be
here there are other areas around
Trafford which have got similar
infrastructure characters this classic
case uh so at this stage I'm saying I
would be voting recommendation to use
this
C on on the other side afraid so I think
that actually um we do we have in part
and remember um approving um battery
storage to Outland um as it were on
green belt because because of the
special nature of it um I think
actually the state that we're in B I
think that we actually need this more um
I get there is harm I accept there is
harm but I think that the um there is
harm by not doing it I think there's
more harm by not doing it um to to
climate so I think I'm
actually I'm seeing it the other way
around the afid and I'll be proposing
that we actually um accept actually
Grant this application on grounds that
actually the the the harm by not doing
it is actually also there um and
actually by the the special
circumstances do I think exist to allow
it to happen so that's what my proposal
is I think special I disagree with I
understand that officers looked at it
and they I come to a different
conclusions right so I think I I'll be
I'll be proposing we do Grant
it um this is a a terribly difficult
application there's no doubt about it
whatsoever um when I went to this site I
I cycled down past Jackson
onto the Mery did a right turn then cyle
down one of the public foot paaths
there's no doubt this is a beautiful
part of a green B but there's absolutely
no doubt about it and we can't diminish
that in any way at all um but according
to the National Grid we do need 20 gaw
of battery storage by 2030 that current
current capacity across the country is
only 2.1 gws so we are in a a rush to
kind of create this battery storage this
Council of course declared the green
party's climate emergency um in
2018 and and and the the B has a carbon
neutral Target
2038 so that is an incredibly big weight
and I think when you look at the um the
green belt statement AFC um 7.4 in in
the green Pates statement did say that
they looked at alternative locations and
they were investigated and that included
the Caron area as mentioned but also the
Trafford industrial estate but there was
no capacity found a distribution level
that would defeat feed directly back
into the local network at those sites so
I think this is probably one of the few
sites in the burough that could be a
possible location for this so that is
also swaying me but again it is green
Bel and the mdpf is is quite clear
paragraph 138 and but if you look at the
five purposes that the mpf does give I
think when you look at SC um it
definitely is in crunch on the country
side um
and the office planning officer did talk
about a cumulative effect but however
this will be removed after 25 years and
turned back into reel hopefully and and
OB the five other purposes he talks
about unrestricted spr I just don't
believe this battery storage unit is
unrestricted for I don't believe it's
meets the second purpose of neighboring
towns merging it's not to neighboring
towns merging um It also says um that um
it should be preserving the historic
character of towns so you I think we can
out rule that that purpose but also it
also talks about Urban regeneration and
encouraging the recycling of D doct land
in urban centers and I think that's
also you know doesn't fit here so I do
think this is a really really tough
application to come down on but for me I
think I I will be kind of seconding
council Minister's proposal to go
against officer recommendation of
refusal thank you
chair
thank you councelor just to come back on
the a couple of your points come to you
Council it is to me quite clearly it is
EV it is and it is um it is going to
damage the aspect of the of that se of
the green belt and it will it will
reduce the distance between that part
tra and short it's in my
view
counc a difficult one this
we seem to be doing it the wrong way
around we've had to suming up we' had to
two proposals I'm to start asking some
questions before I even reach it here
and I don't feel that I'm there yet
um
so it seems just looking at the picture
behind you that there's a pressure to
develop this particular area only this
particular area Valley seems to be
the place for this storage capacity and
I haven't really been given a reason as
to why I almost feel that there should
be some
strategic um spatial document across
right to Manchester that identify areas
for this much needed facility
because if we throw this one out we'll
probably get another one on one of these
fields at the bottom
because well no those are already passed
I'm saying we'll get another one a new
proposal yeah so we are getting pressure
in this stretch along here which bothers
me because we haven't got any guidance
that says whether this is a particularly
suitable place for it or is not a
suitable space and if it's not a
suitable space where are the appropriate
places for a much needed facility to
store and feed in electricity because if
it if it requires Green
Fields sites then we're restricting that
availability by quite a lot because much
of it is green belt and I don't get that
and I'm not getting that from the
argument that been put forward what I'm
seeing is up to now four applications
within about less than a kilometer apart
all in the same area so and three of
them have been
passed and it seems to me as though I
should have some guidance that says why
that is happening and if there is
somewhere else for it if it's not
somewhere else then I want um some
guidance as to what we do I hope that
makes sense but I feel I'm lucky in the
information that I require to make a
decision
okay thank you
c yeah thank you chair um the reason we
have had the number of applications we
had here is it because it is near good
connection that that that's that's a
fact you can see this big gray thing
here there's a awful lot of electricity
goes through that so um that that that's
the reason the proposals are coming here
because it's uh they don't need that
much wiring to get into the grid so that
that makes them the viable to build
um we have also had a number of these
proposals a large number of these
proposals in fact the biggest one in
Europe uh put forward and granted in
Carrington not on Green Belt land so
around Carrington power station is is
what is becoming an energy HB and an
energy Focus uh where we are seeing all
types of energy development uh and
particularly these these um battery
storage at least two or three of these
battery battery storage things with
other energy development as well around
the power station um so and Carrington
is a suitable area for this you don't um
the because much of Carrington although
some remains in the green but of course
Place everyone is dealing with that um
Carrington is a is a suitable area to
for for these and there there there are
other connections there as well which is
why why we have that
H um e there are Connections in in trael
park or be at traffic Park is a lot more
built up already sites there are fewer
available sites particularly at this
scale and if they and and land values
are much higher as well um because they
have they have industrial percent on
them whereas the land value here is
agricultural unless you can get
something else away on
it um in terms of an overall strategy
for energy development um if if we
wanted to decide that this area was
going to be for energy development what
we what we should do properly uh albeit
all this stuff is coming forward we
having to doal with eff planning
applications is release it from the
green belt and allocate it in the local
PL because this is an area that we
should that that we should use but then
of course you would need to weigh that
that allocation and that would need to
be examined and the impact
recreationally visually landscape so
because there's no get away from the
fact that the river Mery is an
incredibly valuable recreational
Corridor for residents of this B uh you
know a green love place where people who
live in very buil of areas can escape to
you know in short time from their homes
it's accessible by foot cycle and by car
as well if if they want to um and you
know that harm has been identified by
officers and that harm should weigh just
as much in the balance as any harm to
Green Belt um I suppose and the other
thing is about the cumulative impact yes
we have granted three others of these as
you can see you can also see from those
yellow boxes they're much
smaller um they are and they don't
encroach as as much this is very big and
very harmful therefore the bar to to get
over to the very special circumstances
is much much much higher than it would
be for those because of the sheer scale
of this this is huge um so yeah so it's
not that we are have said well three are
all right and now this one isn't this
one is much more harmful for a number of
reasons landscape in terms of uh uh in
terms of the way it f fills in the
cumulative impact you know at some point
when do we stop otherwise you know this
this as you say this area will become
full um
so those those differences in the in the
way we look at each application each on
its merits the fact that in the green
belt um the fact that is is so large and
so harmful that is why we've got to
where we are um and and that is why
we're saying that yes all right we get
that you were close to a good connection
we get that this is a suitable place for
that reason but this this is too this is
too
big thank you m do you have any question
just to say that was incredibly helpful
to me that was just what I needed thank
you very
much thank you chair um yes incredibly
difficult issue this isn't it you know
in a wider sense you would want to
approve this because of the the benefits
in terms of carbon reduction and there
there's some economic um benefit the
local community as well which is lesser
incomes but significant but I think as
we've just shared I think the size of
the the proposed development is
significant it's not good one relatively
small and it's going to have a a big
impact on on the Green
Belt the J people um and I think that
that's the major thing we needed to do I
think Landscaping does help actually I
think talk about negative aspect of that
but I think that would help but Le still
look of it it's significant could uh
push that I can see why that then shifts
the planning case in terms of what your
recommended so I would go against
them
for against these proposals even
despite not really wanting to because of
the benefits of it and maybe they can
look at other sites as well can move to
which reasonable benefit to is that is
that proposing that we we go in line off
recommendation uh I can do
yes I'll try and keep it brief um I
completely agree with what Mr cus said
in it is I believe encroachment it's
obviously encroachment you can just see
from from the picture uh and I don't
think we should be looking at the
previous approved developments and and
using that as a judgment for this
particular development just because
those others have been approved doesn't
mean that this gets you know a bit of a
pass I think that's really important to
consider also when we talk about the
environmental and the green uh element
of this I don't really think that
exists when you think about the the
minerals and the materials that are
required to create these batteries on
this scale and where they're coming from
you do a bit of research about the
mining but it's required to get these
resources it is incredi incredibly
damaging not to traford but to place in
Africa East Asia wherever else they all
come from
now there are plenty of other locations
for a place like this and I agree with m
coing carington is exactly that I think
it would be really really poor on us to
approve this um and I will be voting in
line with officer's
recommendations thank you C any else
wish to
speak
any AB if any else wish to speak yeah
the debate has
really pushed me towards the the the
um uh the position I think from the
start of the meeting I don't I have
heard nothing which I was I was
concerned of this being in the green
belt I was concerned that there were
other um other sides where it could be
nothing in this meeting which is which
is to move me away from away from that's
why I'm happy to second that we refuse
this in line with officer recommendation
so we' got
two thanks chair as I said when I think
I started um must be this is an
incredibly difficult decision um and
hearing the other speak and I I think I
probably will remove my second to you as
a motion um yeah I think I'm kind of
persuaded by what others have said I'm
hearing from head count also um it
does tick me back a little bit it was
close to cool for me um you know the
benefits of this are massive I think
everybody here spoken would agree with
that um but of also as I said at the
beginning of my spee also traveling
through this site on bike is a you know
the importance of the green it does have
to be a very
significant consideration and just
hearing every speak I think it's just
hit me the other way so
I'm coun Hass right thank you I
think m is a very good question because
I myself was going on uh but M has
given a very a part of working and a
comprehensive answer of consum highy and
it is the right place we cannot set a
president saying oh there are already
three but there sies are very very small
sizes so this is a very huge kind of
project coming in and hampering and
creating problem for the green Bel and
all those things and I'm fully agreed
with my colleagues those who have said
to go into fully recommendation of of
you recommendations and this is not a
right place uh for such kind of a
business buiness to be hon since
carington is the right place where we've
been with over the fees visited last
couple of months ago and it is a huge
place available for such kind of project
so I fully recommend uh offic
segmentation and refuse this
application okay thank you Council so
it's been proposed seconded that weuse
this application l a
recommendation fav that please
indicate
and all those
against so that has been refused andite
recomendation nextend
is yes would you take a five minute
break
then
[Music]
hey
Shar
yeah yeah that's why that's
why
EX
[Music]
my
I
about
was
you're
[Music]
than
okay everybody chair Steeps out of this
meeting he's have some discussion in
previous times about the application and
uh you won't be taking part in it and
the vice chair about be chairing this
particular item so it's 10 Alder made
present uh
11845 that's page 47 on your agenda
we've got an introduction first of all
for Mr
day thank you um so this application
relates to a two-story semi detached
dwelling house located to the south of
alir C
Fon um has been reported to committee
because more than six objections have
been received cont to the officer
recommendation retrospective Planning
Commission is sought for the erection of
a single story rear Garden Annex and
alterations to the side boundary
treatment the garden anx is to provide
living accommodation that will be uncy
to the main
dwne the annex is positioned close to
the rear boundary of the garden and
measures 6.52 m in width and 7.16 M in
depth with a flat roof with a maximum
height of 2.8 M where the ground level
is at its
lowest and 2.5 M at its highest
level highest ground there are two
windows to the front elevation and one
set of French doors to the side
elevation the building is finished in
Timber clading to the front elevation
with white render to the side and rear
elevations the accommodation has a
living room bedroom and on Suite with a
small kitchen act within the living
space the building is a minimum of 750
mil from the side boundaries and 920 mil
from the rear boundary The Proposal
includes a small area of decking to its
northeast corner as you can see in the
photograph there
um which is 300 mm above the existing
ground level the application also seeks
retrospective permission for Timber
fencing of up to 2 2.1 met in height to
the side boundaries with numbers 8 and
12 um so if I just run through the the
rest of the slides you can see the first
there looking back um towards the houses
Crescent and the application proper
and the two naving
properties um the view from Al Cresent
itself you can just see the building uh
in the center there
yeah uh the site location plan showing
the boundary of resisting
property um the site plan showing the
actual sighting of the building at the
rear of the
garden uh the internal layout plan
showing a living room bedroom on suite
and there's a small kitchenette within
the living room
space and the elevation
drawings obiously flat roof building
um slight chain in
ground um on the fing
elevations um the key issues for
consideration are the proposal's design
the impact on residential amuny and
highways and parking
officers consider that the proposal
would not have would not have any
unacceptable impact on the immunity of
the occupies of neighboring bus The
Proposal is also considered to be
acceptable in terms of design and visual
amenity and would not have any
unacceptable parking
impacts is therefore considered that the
f is in accordance with polic s of the
core strategy and policies in the
mppf and as such the application is
recommended for
approval thank you
thank you Mr D and we've got speakers
for and against the application and
against the application is can stock got
State can stock thank
you thank you um this is this is a a
statement on behalf of Karen St
Stockwell in August 2022 we became aware
of the applicant's application for
Garden Room giving minimal information
only we requested more details and the
applicants refused the council approved
the Garden Room application
Paris moved in on the 10th of the 3D 23
the council was informed immediately
case officer visit on the 20th of the 3D
23 uh the applicant told the case
officer it was emergency accommodation
for dad who was ill and also it's a
caravan so can be transported the shed
is on stills bolted into the ground on
the 5th of 4 23 the case of has
confirmed a full application for a new
dwelling was required as the shed does
not comply finally the first
retrospective application was submitted
on 30 9th 23 again with minim
information the council have not to our
knowledge validates the applicate
statements or measurements given and
also how the level ground on the
original retrospective application has
managed to gain a reasonable slope up
from the front elevation to the rear
elevation refer to applicant submitted
drawings SE several discrepancies in the
height measurements remain whil we agree
the same supply of utilities which have
been extended to The Shed from the house
the shed is functioning separately now
with main strains electricity water and
TV internet connected with the op
continue to use independently we
respectively ask if as the applicant
suggest the structure is not independent
occupant news the main house why does it
have its kitchen and bathroom which
remain inue today occupants use a side
entrance down the side of the main house
to enter and exit the rear Garden every
side not by the house visitors and
deliveries are by the same rout we
understand the applicant are yet to
apply for building regulations which
surely means the shed hasn't been signed
off for safe to live in as the shed is
primarily made of wood it is a
significant virus to anyone living in it
or near it suddenly it appears the
applicants have been vague misleading
and obstructed throughout this whole
process which have caused unnecessary
delay stress and inconvenience to
everyone involved thank
you thank you m Coy if we take that and
if everybody takes that as a all stop
sat in that chair obviously she's not
here today before I ask anybody to come
up Miss co could you answer some of
those issues that were raised in that
statement so talk the she talks about
several disc refenes presuming that's
about measurements and Heights and
things Ste can look at that and um she
did say about um an onsuite would
imagine the onsuite in the kitchen area
she's talking about how can it be uh
it's claimed to be obviously she's
against it but that those facilities
seem to go against a garden room if I
can call it that g if you could answer
that thank you yeah um so firstly in
respect of the the height of the
building so as um as I explained the
height of the building varies between
2.5 m above ground level and 2.8 m above
ground level because a slight slope um
in the land there
um in in terms of sorry I mean perhaps
need to explain again that
obviously a St of lawful development has
previously been gred for a classy out in
this in this position um now the maximum
height that can be permitted for that
out building is 2.5 M from the highest
ground level so this building would
would have actually complied with that
because it's 2.5 meters measured from
the highest ground level adjacent to the
building um the reason it doesn't comply
is because that that certificate um the
permission developments for that relate
to um buildings that are incidental to
the enjoyment of the dwelling house so
that
means there for example a garden room or
a shed not living accommodation so
that's the reason why it didn't comply
but in terms of height of the building
it would have complied um with that
certificate so I don't know whether
that's that's what's meant in terms of
the the reference to discre height but
but the the technical guidance to um
perit development rights is quite clear
that the height building in terms of R
right is measured from the highest
ground level adjac to the
building yeah so on on that section at
the back of the building it's 2.5 MERS
in height now I understand that the the
case officer um this application has
personally measured the the heights of
the building and verified
that they are as as in the building 2.5
me back and 2.8 me out the front so
hopefully that the any issues about the
flight
um in terms of whether how the how the
accommodation can be ancillary
um
so
um I you know I suppose the point is
that we get we do get quite a few
applications like this every year really
in terms of um the provision of
accommodation um within existing
residential Gardens um that is intended
for use and sary to the um existing
property so
essentially in order for that to be the
case then obviously the occupi of that
building need to be living as part of
the overall household of
um the existing property so at the same
time as that it's understandable that um
people in some situations want some
level of privacy and
um uh some some degree degree of
Independence but still they're still
living as part of the the household
because they're sharing the facilities
um of the existing dwelling in other
respects for example um showing living
room of the property watching TV with
the family having meals with the family
using the washing washing
facilities at at the property
um yeah maybe storage within within the
property so yes there's there's
um living room kitchenet and um onu
bathroom accommodation within the
accommodation but at the same time it's
being
used anary to the existing property it's
not being lived with lived in as as a
totally self-contain separate units so
that's how how you can have those
facilities in there but it's still
answer to ex
question
kitchen
build pronounce it to the main yeah Ian
I mean
obviously uh you know that that does
depend how how how it's used um and
and obviously you could have a situation
where an out building an Annex Building
is permitted for an Annex and
subsequently is used in a different way
for self-contained accommodation but um
that would be difficult in this case the
the relationship to the
existing house
um um of
obviously there would be the
recommendation is that a condition would
be attached requiring that it is
ancillary so it was used for some other
purpose then obviously
um that's that's something that would
require for selfed drawing
so that's fine Steen thank you you uh
we've got another speaker uh for the
application Mr Andy North over Mr nor
like to take a
seat and switch your microphone on you
have three minutes thank you no
problem okay thank you for hearing
out I think the reporters quot most of
the items there's no
point Bing too much apart from the the
anx will be used and sary to the main
residents by the parents of the the
owner of the resident the at the house
so it so that it can care I believe
there's some um additional information
regarding circumstances regarding health
has also
beened and the the planning officer
should have this
um
and regards to the fence the fence was
um most of it was already in place and
new fencing when some light land was
taken out new fencing was put in at the
same level hence the reason why it's 100
Mil over the permit element and that's
why it's part of this
application
um so as I said I don't think I can add
too much more than the the others if if
any has any questions for me more than
this
answer I think you can return you see Mr
thank you very
much
counc thank
you I just wanted to uh ask how you
determine whether a structure like this
is or is not incidental to the enjoyment
of the D how do you actually determine
that yes sorry may maybe I should have
explained that more there's two
there's two terms being used here I
suppose yeah incidental to the enjoyment
of the dwelling house as such and ancy
to the drawing house so
if in order for it to have been a
permitted development uh building that
would didn't need Planning Commission it
would have had to have been incidental
to the enjoyment of the drawing house
which means not for living accomodation
so it's not it's the application doesn't
propose a building that's inent at the
drawing house because it includes living
accomodation but it is proposed as
ancillary to the drawing house because
although it's living accommodation it's
not a separate
self-contained dwelling it's it's to be
used as as part of in connection with
the household of the
existing um the existing household so I
I don't know
whether maybe I don't know whether you
you were maybe asking more how do you
how do you determine whether it is
untill or not well um it's obviously not
incidental is it and um I think when
around the anery side with it having a
bedroom kitchenet living on site you
would in my mind see that as a separate
place where people live um but I wanted
to also ask around what's the exemptions
are around care needs with our buildings
like this as was just briefly stipulated
then the for the elderly parents that
required attention and care and
support I mean there aren't
specific exemptions set out in policy in
terms of that and and the opposite
report um our conclusions are the The
Proposal is
acceptable um it's not dependent on on
an argument in relation to care needs
and there been statement submitted in
relation to that that's obviously not
we've not gone into that in detail
because of um
um
gdpr requirements in terms of um
confidentiality but our view as officers
is that
um The Proposal isn't it isn't dependent
on that in order to be acceptable but
obviously that that is another fact you
know um
it you know as I say it just depend on
how how the building is used um The
Proposal here is clearly that the
building is to be used as ancillary
accommodation um by members of of the
same overall household who will be using
the facilities of the existing house not
not not
solely this facility that that's clearly
been set out in in the statement from
the applican um it wouldn't be used by
somebody
um you know some some independent person
moving in here and renting out the
property as a separate dwelling that's
clearly the basis of the application
that that's the way we have to assess
that obviously if if circumstances were
to change in the future and that was
used in a different way that would need
a different planning
application just just my own
understanding what would it then take
for plan office to determine that this
would not qualify as an ancillary
building would it need more rooms would
it need different types of rooms would
you need to have evidence that people
are separately living there Airbnb or
renting or what would be what would
determine
that sorry honestly the um the scale of
the applic the scale of the
accommodation um does is is
self-limiting to some extent in terms of
um
it's you know it's not something that we
would ever permit as a as a separate
dwelling um for a start because it
doesn't meet the nationally described
space standards for um for a separate
self-contained residential unit so so it
is self-limiting in terms of that to
some extent I mean I think you know
looking looking at the
um the level of accommodation I know
sorry you haven't got photograph of the
internal accomodation on the slideshow
but I mean
uh it is obviously Limited in terms of
scale um you know in terms of whether
somebody want to live in in that
accommodation
purely you know with no other
um uh facil no facility for using the
main houses I think it is self-limiting
in that in any case but we we have to
assess this application on on its I
suppose on on Face Value the application
is um submitted as a householder
application for anciliary accommodation
if if it were
and it's been it's been looked at by
Enforcement Officers by our own
Enforcement Officers they veryify that
that is the way that the the
accommodation is being used at the
moment if if it were you know if there
were an attempt to use it in a different
way in the future if it you know for
example if if this if this was letters a
b and b or something then then obviously
that's a different that would be a
different use it would be a
self-contained dwelling and and it would
need a
different it would have to be assessed
under a different planning applications
so
um there are a number of factors in you
know in the assessment as to whether
somebody's using it um um but
um that is the B of this application and
and the officers that Vis of the site
have verified that that that is the way
that it's been used in this instance
thanks very much um I know that point to
the conditions does state that um
combination here by committee should not
be occupied at any other time other than
for purposes and to use the single
dwelling house my concerns really are
that out building is very popular and
and it can be seen as quite a good side
earner for people to put these kind of
buildings at the back of the gardens and
earn a bit of money on the side whether
it's Airbnb whether it's part-time
rentals business public person is coming
around he's staying in every three
months something all that kind lots of
opportunity as we all know there's not a
huge amount of combination not huge
amount of affordable um hotel that
either around so that that's my concern
because because I understand the impact
that has on residents as well when it
comes to people coming in and out of
places if it does turn into an Airbnb in
the future um so I just want to have
some kind of real
around point two if it does end up being
in the future 5 10 15 20 years time in
the future used as a second income for
the people who own the property how how
are the planners going to be aware of
that is it just going to be a case of
residents complaining to to planning or
yeah I mean I think in this case
um to be totally Frank with you we have
had cases OB where where this kind of
permission has been granted and
subsequently they come back and argue
that it's been used as a self-contained
dwelling for at that time they had they
only had to show been users
selfcontained for four years um and
we've had to Grant a certificate in in
in one or two cases because it had
actually been used by that those
circumstances were in uh the one I'm
particularly thinking of was a very long
Garden where the building was took right
at the back of this very long garden and
nobody around it could see what was
happening in this case obviously it's
surrounded by other Residential
Properties I think if if this is
used for self-contain purposes by by
other people unrelated to um the
household then I think I think that's
quite clearly going to be immediately on
um the neighbor's radar in this case and
we're obviously likely to get complaints
about that and then it will be down to
reinforcement
um section to to pursue that inv that
but that's not the basis of the
application
um that's not the basis of this
proposal final comment I just thank you
really I'm just wanted to get a better
understanding of the situation with that
but thank you I will be voting in line
with the offic recommendations thank you
you councel councel
mland thank you chair so you proposing
I'll second that proposal and I'm
visiting this it's a beautiful little
building at the bottom of the garden
it's evidently a gram flat uh to um and
um it doesn't encro on anybody at all as
far as I can see this building so I'm
definitely the
seconding thank you anybody else wish to
comment I went to view today and um went
into the background and I couldn't
honestly see that it would bother the
neighbors as Council
M has said um impact there's a lots of
out buildings quite similar to it in the
area those are long
Gardens in that area so I'm quite
comfortable with it I think um it's been
explained by officers concerns have been
rightly raised I think they've been
dealt with quite reasonably and it's
been proposed and second that we Grant
this application all those in favor
Grant
show
down and vot against that unanimous
application been granted thank you very
much thank you Council wal move on to
the final item on the agenda which is uh
9756 barington Road it's on page one of
your back and Mr day will give the
instuction thank you Mr
day thank you yeah
um this application is reported commit
because an elected member has an
interest in the
application um the application rates the
large such property in use as an agent
and located on the Eastern side of
barington road it was converted
approximately 40 years ago to form seven
flets and one self-contained apartment
spread over three floors where the
basement also recently converted to a
self-contained Department under Planning
Commission
1052 for
21 there's an examp commission for two
roof lights within the principle
elevation which you can see on that um
drawing um under commission one 10741
18422 um that is intended to be carried
out in conjunction with the currently
proposed development this is Planning
Commission um Planning Commission is now
sought for the insertion of one
additional refl within the principal
elevation on the right hand side of the
elevation and um the erection of a Dorma
on the rear
elevation and another re on the
reation the roof light to the front
would relate to flatlet five whereas the
rear roof light would relate to flatlet
seven the proposed D would also would
allow the conversion of a storage room
to a bathroom as part of flat at
seven two representations have been
received um one confirming no objections
to the pros development and the other
raising concerns regarding overlooking
in relation to the property to the
rear the key issues consideration of The
Proposal design and impact on sorry uh
just go through the rest of the slides
that's that's the
point um so that that shows um the
application
propy uh in relation to the property of
the rear um on gasal road
um show the application
propy uh the general street Ste and the
rear where the D would go on top of that
projecting
element
um and the property to the rear one g
Road um there have been amendments to
the originally submitted plans that incl
include a reduction in the size of the
rear dor and repositioning of the DOR
window and the retention of the first
and second story rear windows as
existing with these originally having
been proposed to be reduced in size with
nontraditional
proportions officers consider that the
proposal as amended would not have any
unacceptable impact on the character and
appearance of the street scene or the
surrounding area in terms of impact on
residential amenity the height of the
roof light
overing obviously concerns have been ra
raised by the occupants of number one g
Road to the rear about overlooking from
the D windows but that proposed window
would serve a bathroom and it would be
conditioned to be obscure glaze and
fixture fix sh up to 1.7 meters above
floor level and would therefore also be
compliant with SBD
guidance subjects that condition The
Proposal is therefore considered to be
acceptable in terms of its impact on
Visual imunity and residential
imunity um it would also not result in
any additional parking impacts as
there's no further um flat proposed the
application would therefore comply with
policy 7 of the core strategy and
policies in the mppf and it's
recommended for approval subject to
conditions uh thank you then Mr we've
got no external speakers on this item
any member wish to make a contribution
Council W thanks chair I went down to
look at this today and uh and not at
number one gas and uh the lady said to
the she hadn't received notice on this
planning
application and then know she been in
touch with the planning team about fact
that could M Coy comment on that on Mr
da thank you if you will Mr
day yeah um I mean our record was on the
application file do show um that a nav
notification letter was sent to all the
immediately adjoining properties
including number one Jas Ro
obviously our records can only show what
what letters we we generated we we can't
we can't know for sure that that letter
was delivered by the postal service but
um clearly we have we have sent out a
letter relating to this
um um so yeah we don't know we don't
sure whether that was delivered or
whe whe whether they for some reason
didn't didn't pick up L but um it was it
was sent out as far our records are
clear that it was sent out you okay that
yeah of course um so I've gotten T spoke
to the lady lat she told is she been in
touch with the with the planning team
she's asked that this item be deferred
because she didn't have time to collect
a thoughts to present concerns that
other members will have other views I'm
sure that she said could we defer so so
she could have a proper look at the
plans and and discuss it and and no
object to it she's directly behind it
she's she's very Inc comfortable with
it put that to your chair would would be
considered defer to the members uh my
instinct is not to declare it um I think
the the the reason why this is in to Vis
the committee it's because interest from
um a member of the council I think under
normal circumstances this would have
been uh decided
under delegated powers by officers but
if anybody else wishes to second to def
on this I'm happy to listen to
that any wish second
okay questions always
welcome is do we know that's the only
person who didn't get get a letter
effectively or do we know the others all
definitely
gotten because if it's a case out and
all he say got no objections to it um I
mean obviously our record show a letter
was sent out to one
road but um we we we obviously don't
know about the other properties but I
don't think anybody
else is likely to be affected
by to speak on the item okay I'm uh
happy to propose that we accept this in
line with opposite recommendations
anybody have to second that two second
is over there so
the
sorry well thanks for the opportunity to
check I'm grateful for that um just just
talking about the the uh the Doral
window today um when I read at paragraph
17 um which recommended that the windows
conditioned to excore glazing and non
opening up to 1.7 m above the internal
floor
level significant shortfall in the
backto back
distance is that same that the the
window can be partially open it's a
bathroom it's going to get going to get
steamy in there isn't it it's going to
have to be open some
point I know maybe that maybe that
condition is difficult to to interpret
perhaps but um essentially it means that
um it would need to be fix sh up to 1.7
MERS above FL level above that height um
there would there would be the potential
for a top open
window right so somebody stood there
could could open the window at the top
they wouldn't be able to put real effort
there I
think getting
overing that's the concern that's
question I mean I mean the the window is
approximately 9 M from the boundary
maybe at an angle it's slight sorry
slightly less than 9 M but it's not as
though it's you know maybe if it was 3 m
from the ground you think maybe somebody
could could looked out that window but I
think he would be pretty restricted it
position is within our
guidelines that's what it's a standard
condition that we
apply so it's been proposed seconded
that we approve this all those in favor
could you please
indicate that thank
you thank you that concludes the meeting
so thank you M for your participation
wish you all a very merry Christmas
happy New
Year good night
all